les manifestations se multiplient dans la ville ce
matin après un attentat à la bombe présumé
qu'avez-vous un Michael Mason
mandats en circulation dans quatre États avec
large alors allons les chercher discrètement d'
accord
cela ne vous semble pas bon oh
merde j'ai volé le dos mais je  Je ne savais pas
qu'il y avait une bombe dedans mais tu as couru des
innocents ne cours pas le bijoutier qui
vient après moi tu t'es vu
doit être vraiment bon et le meilleur s'approcher
de moi et voler mon portefeuille toujours là
l'argent est parti donne moi que le  la bombe a
été faite par un policier en civil
vos mâchoires pour fermer ça manquez-le
Michael vous voulez effacer votre nom allez-
y obtenez-moi un contrat principal c'est une
opportunité tout est une question de
distraction
bon travail je ne travaille pas pour la CIA  les villes
sont la menace qu'ils ont faite aujourd'hui nous avons eu un
complot ils ont posé une autre bombe je
pense que vous avez la mauvaise adresse
nous sommes compromis c'étaient des
masques à gaz tactiques ces gars ne sont pas des amis des flics oui
avec une ville en ce moment nous avons un travail à faire
vous devriez vraiment penser à la
gestion de la colère sèche votre petit-déjeuner et le
responsable ne peut pas simplement vouloir
allumer le feu
vous le faites vous-même sur votre propre sèche-linge et
que pouvons-nous faire il n'y a que deux d'entre nous
que faites-vous seul pas de
plan pas de sauvegarde  Je suis téméraire et
irresponsable puis-je obtenir une arme à feu